[Music]  we've made it this far there's a  stairway beyond those doors and at the  top the soul chamber I feel it so very  was neck deep in [ __ ] town of the  business end of an outhouse he picked a  bad place to hide in the worst place to  die  [Music]  [Music]  follow my lead  coughing that's secrets it's bad to bury  it is the Khans business Baraka we're  equal partners remember  have Kaunas business is business  [Music]  you are not sure  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  and I was that for strange bedfellows  what do you say we skip the  preliminaries and y'all come with us  quietly we'll have a nice friendly chat  with katana Todd there's no time for  chat we must get to the soul chamber  urgently and go on and get to it but  we're taking shape soon and that coffin  [Applause]  my sincere apologies  [Music]